such insignificant
creatures
they dare steal from galactus
for that i will destroy
their planet
how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel
and everything relating to the mcu
official news
leaks rumors reports anything about
marvel we talk about right here and
today mikey sutton has
officially launched his new website
geekocitymag.com
and to celebrate he is dropping two new
scoops of what he's heard
in the rumor mill at marvel studios and
they are very
very exciting one concerning the big
bad planet devouring galactus and the
other
the midnight sun's a group that a lot of
mcu fans have been waiting to see show
up in the mcu for a pretty long time now
and
especially since marvel studios has
announced blade
is on its way so we'll break it all down
but first if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
mcu news and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win a
doctor strange
funko pop all you have to do to enter
subscribe like the video and leave a
comment down below
so to kick it off we're going to start
with galactus
he is not a villain he is merely hungry
a cosmic
god with an appetite for planets in the
mcu galactus will finally be shown in
his jack kirby glory
a regal ethereal figure he is also
morally gray one would rather consume
uninhabited planets to feed on
unless of course there is no alternative
at the moment
sure enough galactus will destroy worlds
with billions of lives striking terror
throughout space
and according to what mikey has heard
currently the plan is to not have
galactus be the big bad
until the third fantastic four movie
until then he will be teased and built
up when galactus appears he will have
the silver surfer with him
but temporarily temporarily because
spoiler alert the surfer will betray him
only
to have johnny storm's girlfriend
frankie ray take his place
there's no script or filmmakers attached
yet but the game plan is being
outlined fantastic 4-3 is just the
beginning for galactus as he will take
an even larger role in secret
wars so let's talk about this for a
second before we get into the midnight
suns because i have done plenty of
videos on galactus in the past in fact
i've done one this week
everybody wants to know what's up with
galactus everybody wants to know when he
will be coming and of course we all
assume that he would be attached to the
fantastic four
but if marvel is planning on introducing
frankie rey that could make for a very
interesting story and a very interesting
build up of galactus
for starters if you don't know who
frankie rey is she is another version
of the human torch and she's also as
mentioned
johnny storm's girlfriend frankie gets
her powers from an
accident her dad is actually the person
who created the first
human torch which was an android frankie
got her powers through an accident which
involved horton cells
breaking all over her body dousing her
and bursting her into flames but she
survived and found
out that she had the power to burst into
flames anytime she wanted to and could
even control nearby fires now her dad
didn't want people to know about her so
he hypnotized her and made her forget
about her powers he also put on her a
suit that suppressed her powers but he
also hypnotized her to where she
couldn't see it
now eventually her subconscious would
attract her to
johnny storm the human torch and mr
fantastic quickly found out that she was
hypnotized and he also discovered her
suit
so he undid the hypnosis and the
fantastic four agreed to let her join
the fantastic four
as a second human torch however this was
short-lived however this would soon be
interrupted by
galactus despite galactus making an oath
to spare
earth he had to come back to earth
because he was desperate but in order to
save the planet frankie made a deal with
him to become
his herald and that was the end of
frankie with the fantastic four
now the interesting part about this
story is that galactus has come to earth
made an oath not to consume earth goes
away but comes back again
and this is something that we very well
could see happen in the mcu
with galactus we know that they're going
to tease galactus we know it's going to
be kind of like thanos
thanos just didn't pop up out of nowhere
they teased him
over the course of 10 years he made his
debut technically in avengers end game
in the post-credits scene we then saw
him in guardians of the galaxy
and then next in age of ultron until we
finally saw him in infinity war and of
course
endgame so we're going to see galactus a
few times and perhaps
one of those few times is going to be
him coming to earth but then vowing to
spare earth but of course
in exchange for a herald because we also
know that the silver surfer is coming as
well but of course much like the comics
he will betray galactus
the next thing that mikey has heard is
about the midnight suns
they live for darkness the hellish
heroes of
midnight sons have been tossed back and
forth between tv and film the past few
years in terms of development
jeff loeb originally wanted them for
hulu with ghost rider and hellstrom
but that changed when suddenly blade was
green
lit and now mikey has heard that the
midnight suns are being positioned to
form
in blade 2 with the johnny blaze ghost
rider discussion to cameo in the first
movie
and who else will be in the midnight sun
you can head over to lords of the long
box to discover the lineup and mikey
will also post it on his website
gagositymag.com
ever since the president of marvel
studios kevin feige announced
blade at san diego comic con in 2019
people have been expecting that we could
possibly be getting the midnight suns
and since then there have been several
reports that we are in fact going to be
getting them and it does in fact look
like marvel studios could be developing
their own
monster verse and we know that marvel
studios is actually going to have
several different teams in the mcu
starting in phase four
of course we're going to have the
avengers but then we're going to have
the x-men the fantastic four we're also
going to have
the young avengers but then marvel is
going to go a different way than they've
gone before
they're going to introduce teams that
are a little bit darker
and this is going to include the
thunderbolts and the midnight suns
now with the midnight suns there are
possibilities that weren't really
possible before because the midnight
suns will exist in marvel's little own
monster verse and there have been some
great characters that have been in the
midnight suns in the comics
and in fact we already know of some that
are in the mcu already
doctor strange of course is in the
midnight suns and then elsa bloodstone
has been rumored to be in doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness and she's
in the midnight suns as well
then of course we have blade in which
case this report says is pretty much
going to set up the midnight suns as
many people expected
and not to mention moon knight has been
announced as well
so the team could really be quite
fantastic plus even more characters
could be coming to the mcu that we don't
know about and again you can check out
lords of the lomboks for the rumored
lineup so as it's been revealed over
time and as we're hearing about now
marvel actually has quite a bit of
different plans for the mcu in their
upcoming phases
instead of being just one team that
builds up to ultimately fight against a
big bad
there are going to be many different
teams all of which have their own
villains to fight but will ultimately
all come together in the end when marvel
does their next avengers in-game level
event
secret wars in which case galactus will
be there
waiting for all of our heroes with some
other villains as well
and marvel is going to treat galactus
much like they treated thanos
teasing him a few times before actually
making his marvel cinematic universe
debut as the main
big bad villain but where do you think
he'll show up in the meantime and when
do you think
marvel is going to tease him for the
very first time and what do you think
about the silver surfer betraying him
and frankie ray
becoming his herald how would you like
to see this play out and also let me
know what you think about the midnight
suns let me know all your thoughts about
galactus and the midnight suns in the
comments down below also don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
mcu news and rumors as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof